uh I want you to know that it is not
easy for me to say I agree with you in
this case
I think the left hatred
of us is so great
that a certain amount of joy
would be in their hearts they wouldn't
express it of course
if if Florida were hurt
and by the way I don't think it's
symmetrical
I loathe what the Democrats have done to
where I still live in California
it would bring me no joy if some natural
disaster hit California
I I don't think there's symmetry in in
the uh in the hatreds
I'm Dave Rubin and joining me today is
the founder of prageru as well as the
author of the brand new book the
rational Bible Deuteronomy God blessings
and curses Dennis Prager welcome back to
the Reuben report
I love being with you great to be there
Dennis I am always happy to talk to you
my first question is you've written
according to my research uh
351 books this is your uh
2477th appearance on the Reuben report
which one of those would you say is a
higher Accolade for you
if they were to put one on my Tombstone
it will definitely be the Reuben report
appearances
when you wait I mean think about it you
weigh the Bible
and then the Dave Rubin report come on
come on how many books is this for you
for real I mean you this has got to be
you know what this is very interesting I
have no idea what this will say about me
positive negative or neither
I don't know how many books I've written
but I do know exactly how many countries
I have visited how many countries have
you visited
131 wow Slovakia was my 131st last year
what's uh what's remaining for you I
mean do you have anything that you
haven't gotten to yet it's getting tough
Rwanda haven't been to Rwanda haven't
been to Mongolia I mean the the you know
I've been to 20 African countries but I
think there are 40. so you know you know
I've been on my mission to get you to
move to Florida but I see Rwanda is in
your heart
that is very funny I I Rwanda was for a
visit
Florida hey by the way are you worried
about the hurricane
so as we're recording this right now you
know I'm in Miami so it looks like it it
hit the West Coast unbelievably hard
like category five uh my folks have a
place over there that were just praying
isn't going to be destroyed uh but oh
God but to bring it to a little bit of
the politics and then we'll get into the
book I mean DeSantis is doing everything
possible but the media is just waiting
are you feeling that were you talking
about that on your radio show this
morning that the media is just waiting
for one disaster to really strike so
they can say this is the thing and he's
incompetent and he's evil and awful and
like they would love for Destruction
basically is what I'm saying
uh I want you to know that it is not
easy for me to say I agree with you in
this case
I think the left hatred
of us is so great
that a certain amount of joy
would be in their hearts they wouldn't
express it of course
if if Florida were hurt
and by the way I don't think it's
symmetrical
I loathe what the Democrats have done to
where I still live in California
it would bring me no joy if some natural
disaster hit California
I I don't think there's symmetry in in
the uh in the hatreds well well that
symmetry or that asymmetry as you put
that's sort of connected to what this
book is about because it's about God and
the Bible and goodness and things of
that nature and and you know that I'm
sort of you as I sort of call you my
you're my quote unquote Rabbi and we're
actually taping this right in between
Rosh Hashanah and Yom Kippur so this is
an important week for the Jewish people
to reflect on life and all that stuff
and you've you've reconnected me with a
lot of these things
um that there's a reason for that
asymmetry I think that politics is their
world view while generally speaking more
conservative leaning people and I don't
mean that purely in a conservative sense
politically but conservative leaning
people have another ideology so it does
make sense right I would go further we
have another life it's so interesting
you should mention that
so I think you know but I'm sure most of
your viewers don't or listeners
I have been conducting the Jewish High
holy day Services as if I were a rabbi
I'm not I'm not ordained but as as so to
speak a rabbi for 15 years this was the
15th year
about 400 people attend
oh you've attended actually I've I've
been many times actually the first time
I was there was about four years ago or
so you were giving the sermon and you
were discussing something about same-sex
couples and you referenced David and I
being dinner at our house a few days
before you didn't even know I was there
I did not I mean we were there that's
right but I've been many times in its
standing room only and it's and it's
wonderful what you do ordained or not
yeah exactly so I want to comment on on
your point about the the different life
so first by the way I just want for
those interested they can watch my
service anytime they want till January
1st now or anytime at salemnow.com
just so they should know that and the
music is incredible by the way you get
people the music is incredibonic and all
sorts of stuff I don't know it's it's
the whole thing I explain everything
non-jews watch it even more than Jews do
because they're a lot more non-jews than
Jews but but it appeals to everybody so
anyway I actually
noted on my show when I returned from my
two-day break
how important it is in my life that I
have another life a life of religion
and when you when one doesn't have that
and everything everything is secular
there is a real Danger
that and this is the danger of the left
part of it everything is then politics
everything the purpose of your life the
meaning it's it's your interest it's
your passion
it's not my interest it's not my passion
my I I'm passionate about about the
ultimate questions of life which is why
I'm writing my Bible commentary because
if people understand the first five
books which are by far the most
important in all of the Bible
Jesus would have said that as as Jesus
uh and uh and as a Jew which he was the
most important books actually ever
written
and you will find this fascinating I
just learned this sadly after I'd
already completed Deuteronomy it's the
fifth book but it's my third I didn't go
in order
and you will find this fascinating as I
did
the founders of the country cited
Deuteronomy more than any other
religious or secular work
in in the in their writings and in their
speeches that's how much this book
influenced the creation of the freest
country ever made and and so that that
should be if if one needs one and I
think does one need one most people
never heard of Deuteronomy but it is it
is a phenomenal work of the five books
it's Moses's summary of everything
this Israelites this humanity is what is
important I'll give you one example so I
wrote a column for Fox giving seven
great
insights just from the book
do not show partiality and judgment
there is a specific law
in both Exodus and Deuteronomy you
cannot it's specific you'll love this
Dave you cannot favor the poor man who
comes into your court justice is Justice
it is like a law against social justice
there was only Justice it's basically
it's a law against Equity that's that's
sort of a talk exactly
equity and Liberty are mutually
exclusive
that's exactly right if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about spirituality instead
of non-stop yelling check out our
spirituality playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out our full episode
playlist they're all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell